if it isn't a wild stallions when your
wives suggested couples therapy do you
think this is what they had in mind
definitely you were a couple of couples
right Ted enough of the delusions you
didn't time travel and you didn't go to
heaven and hell there's a vo idea for
you be role models to your daughter get
real jobs bill
we've spent our whole life trying to
unite the world and I'm tired dude Ted
we have a destiny to fulfill Oh
greetings my excellent friend we have a
problem
step forward a song created by Preston
Logan
performing tonight will save reality as
we know it
oh did you better write that so now why
can't we just go to the future when we
have written it take it from ourselves
except won't that be stealing Cheers
what was that stealing for stealing it
from ourselves
[Music]
dude that's a Punto fijo come out
[Applause]
no way how's it going dude we're gonna
go talk to dad is he playing hopscotch
by yourself dude is cheating hey death
life isn't a wild stallion excellent to
each other and party on oops
[Music]
how you doing well you know dad and
we're in hell but how you doing
[Music]
you
[Music]
you